les cérémonies qui se dérouleront demain
ne feront pas oublier que cinq cent
mille personnes d'une façon ou d'une
autre avec eux lavaur et avec la stasi
oui les archives qui regroupe la liste
de ces taupes est-allemande va bientôt
revenir ses archives à berlin reportage
de notre correspondant sur place au jay
lerner
on est comme écrasé par s'est rangée
sans fin tout le poids de l'histoire de
l'ex allemagne de l'est et là c'est le
travail des espions des collaborateurs
des employés et les de la stasi des
employés qui n'ont pas eu le temps de
détruire à l'acide
cette montagne de documents secrets pris
de court par la chute du mur
voilà dix ans qu'il fouille dans ses
sacs ou bertus nab historien écrivain il
n'hésite pas à prendre beaucoup de
risques personnels pour faire tomber un
autre mur celui du silence est née
ch'tis flèche à l'ouest
il n'y avait pas de surveillance sur
tout le pays par contre à l'est une
véritable toile d'araignée a été tissée
ont voté dans l'ensemble 509
collaborateurs officiels et officieux
qu'aux frontières
à l'ouest ils agissaient sur les centres
nerveux de la société pas seulement dans
les partis politiques ou les
organisations mais il essayait
d'étouffer au cas par cas ceux qui
critiquaient le régime et le parti
unique est-allemand les années noires
s'ouvre enfin aux allemands de l'est
comme de l'ouest qui veulent savoir
chacun peut venir ici consulter son
dossier ragot dénonciation rapports
intimes écrits à la main
les collaborateurs de la stasi avait la
plus facile la plupart des dossiers
politiques sont comme ça broyé mais tout
n'est pas perdu pour autant
avant de plier bagage la stasi a copié
pour les russes la liste des ses
effectifs la cia a racheté le tout à
moscou et va renvoyer cette matière
précieuse aux allemands qui se perdait
dans des reconstitutions s'en fait
encore des années pour reconstituer ses
puzzles oui si on le fait comme ça
parmain fait ça fait je crois 300 années
alors tout coup le temps peut-être trop
de temps les américains vont accélérer
ce travail de fourmi en livrant 317
mille noms
agent secret est victime confondues la
liste des taupes risque de faire grand
bruit en allemagne